Jada Pinkett Smith gets candid about her
own struggle with mental health one day
I woke up and I was withered
curled up in a ball about to - on Monday
the 46 year old actress took to
Instagram with an emotional post
reflecting on the recent suicides of
Kate Spade and Anthony Bourdain quote it
brought up feelings of when I was in
such despair and had considered the
scene demise often she went on to write
about her healing process explaining how
she makes her mental health a daily
practice quote how I care for my body my
spiritual practice what people I
surround myself with the amount of
stress I allow and so on either
contribute to or deteriorate my mental
health this isn't the first time the
girls trip star has talked about her
struggles in May she got candid about
her journey while chatting with
seventeen-year-old daughter Willow on
her Facebook watch series read tabletop
when the producer first asked me you
know what was the biggest loss of had in
my life I said myself Wow and then when
you realize that you've lost yourself
that's like devastating that's just like
how do I get myself back
you